[Música]
en la catedral de Yuba un gran número de
estos zursulaneses acuden para celebrar
la misa dominical
referencias a la paz entre etnias manos
tendidas a los políticos el arzobispo
quiere ser reconciliador en la primera
visita del Papa al país
[Música]
Recuerden que cuando el pontífice se
reunió con nuestro presidente y
vicepresidente dijo
mantengan la paz quiere que cada uno de
nosotros traiga la paz porque no solo el
gobierno puede hacerlo
[Música]
alcanzar la Paz es el papel de cada uno
de nosotros
tras décadas de lucha contra el Sudán
musulmán Sudán del sur obtuvo la
independencia en 2011 la Iglesia
Católica ha estado apoyando el país
todos estos años y sigue jugando un
papel en 2019 fue el Papa Francisco
quien reunió a los dos hombres al
comienzo de la guerra civil durante la
cual murieron cientos de miles de
personas
los lugares de culto se consideran un
espacio de mediación donde los políticos
pueden intentar resolver conflictos
hago un llamamiento a todos los Sur
sudaneses para que mantengan la paz en
el país durante la visita papal
a pesar de la aplicación gradual de los
acuerdos de paz los combates continúan
en algunas zonas para superarlo El
Vaticano intenta influir en los debates
presionando a las élites
desempeña un papel destacado en Sudán
del sur Aunque solo un tercio de la
población es católica el país también
cuenta con muchos practicantes de
religiones tradicionales y fieles de
otras iglesias cristianas
muchos políticos han estudiado en
escuelas católicas respetan la
institución en la que también confía la
población para este analista esto
Explica las expectativas de los Sur
sudaneses ante la visita papal
de hecho fueron las escuelas de la
iglesia las que facilitaron la entrada
de los Sur sudaneses en el mundo moderno
pero sin forzar ni imponer su voluntad
sino aportando conocimiento y
comprensión
para él es gracias a la educación
impartida a los estudiantes de todas las
religiones que la iglesia Ha logrado
establecerse en el país y ser aceptada
por la mayoría de la población uniría al
pueblo Mientras que el gobierno
responsable de la guerra civil no puede
hacerlo como símbolo de este papel las
ongs católicas están presentes en todo
Sudán del sur la comunidad de Don Bosco
se estableció en Yuba en la década de
1980 utiliza la escuela para inculcar
sus principios venimos de tribus
diferentes de comunidades diferentes
Pero se ve que en don Bosco convivimos
muy bien y no discriminamos y creo que
cuando salgamos de este lugar podremos
cambiar las cosas
a causa de la guerra y los conflictos
étnicos 4 millones de personas siguen
viviendo lejos de sus hogares dos
millones están refugiadas en el
extranjero el resto están desplazadas
dentro de su propio país sobre todo en
campamentos este financiado por Don
Bosco acoge a mil familias desde 2013
Samsung es uno de los responsables aquí
hoy se con un grupo de mujeres para
hablar de su protección
Antes había pequeños conflictos pero
ahora Gracias a nuestra labor de
sensibilización conviven en armonía
aunque las tensiones han disminuido y
los combates han cesado en muchas zonas
no todo el país está en paz
inaugurada en 2018 la embajada del
Vaticano sigue afirmando que trabaja
para unir a la gente para el emisario de
la santa sede la visita del Papa podría
contribuir a presionar más para obtener
resultados concretos
la iglesia y especialmente el pontífice
esperan sinceramente que esta visita
contribuyan a reforzar el compromiso por
la paz
de modo que los dirigentes del país es
decir el presidente salvar el vi y las
demás facciones políticas del país se
sienten realmente a la mesa para
encontrar una solución pacífica a largo
conflicto
este papel se explica por el carácter
altruista de la religión como símbolo de
este deseo de traer la paz el papa
visita el país con representantes de las
iglesias calvinista y anglicana algo
nunca antes visto pero la influencia que
la Iglesia Católica intenta ganar es
también estratégica con 250 millones de
Seguidores África suele considerarse
fundamental para el futuro de la
religión